[Musique]
oh
au petit matin alors que la forêt se
réveille sous son manteau de neige
julien harbec it la chaleur de son logis
pour se rendre dans les bois j'ai pas de
que moins de contraintes que pour les
animaux pour les animaux seraient déjà
cache une de bien chez par puce à la
nuit ou tôt le matin à 37 ans ce
jurassien né à bois d'amont passe la
plupart de son temps dans la forêt déjà
tout petit julien se baladait dans la
nature
appareil photo jetable à la main afin
d'obtenir une image de ce qu il appelle
ses colocataires
bao partagent la même planète on a un
peu tendance à se sentir tout seul mais
on est on est pas forcément chez nous on
est là on rentre dans le territoire de
chevreuils ont le rendre dans le
territoire d'un écureuil d'une mare
tonci plein de monde donc c'est un peu
nos colocataires aujourd'hui photographe
naturaliste professionnel il arpente les
forêts du haut jura
une vie de solitaire qui lui convient
parfaitement c'est là où je fais mon
yoga c'est pas vraiment de yoga mais
c'est s'exposer s'ouvrir à l'envirotron
environnement observés écoutés
disparaître pour voir un peu ce qui est
autour de nous à la forêt c'est un
univers que plein de vie à force
julien connaît sur le bout des doigts la
forêt chaque bruit sur les cimes chaque
empreinte laissée sur la neige sont
autant d'histoires qu'il raconte
toujours avec passion
ça c'est détresse qu'ils sont faciles à
identifier ces lièvres
donc on reconnaît les traces de lièvre
qui sont un pur y
il venait de là bas il va dans cette
direction là et on est sûr à 100% que
c'est le lièvre parce que les deux
traces qui sont à l'avant ici là on a
deux deux empreintes de paul en a deux
autres les empreintes de pas là sont
beaucoup plus grosse que celle là au
contact direct de la forêt depuis
plusieurs années le photographe remarque
bien que l'écosystème est bouleversé
même si certains animaux profitent des
scolytes et des sécheresses pour se
nicher dans les arbres morts ce n'est
pas le cas de tous avec le réchauffement
climatique on a des espèces qui vivent
plus bas en altitude comptant dans sa
remontée
ici donc la chouette hulotte qui était
généralement plus bas en altitude va
avoir tendance à s'installer à c'est
assez facilement ici elle va
concurrencer ou prédaté les petites
chouettes qui sont typiques de la
montagne pendant des heures dans le
froid
julien planque pour obtenir les plus
beaux clichés
[Musique]
mais il a conscience que son travail
implique aussi de respecter les animaux
qu'il photographie l'inconvénient de la
proche à renvoie plus de paysages on
peut se balader suivre les traces mais
par contre comme le renard quiero pays
là si on approche il va sauver
donc il sera plus tranquille on va
l'embêter et puis même pour moi sera
contre-productif parce qu'il sera plus
après
l'économie la passion la transmission
les menaces des scolytes du
réchauffement climatique et la
préservation de la biodiversité
les forêts sont les poumons d'une
planète d'un écosystème fragile qu'il
faut savoir exploiter mais également
préservé
[Musique]